hi everybody welcome to cloud on air
live webinars from Google cloud we're
hosting webinars every Tuesday my name
is Priya Patel and today we'll be
talking about transforming your content
management strategy with box and G suite
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have Googlers on standby
to answer them so let's get started my
name is Priya Patel and I'm the group
product marketing manager at box focused
on our partnerships and integrations I'm
excited to be joined shortly by John
Lake vice-president of enterprise
applications from DocuSign who's going
to join us live for Q&A to learn about
how DocuSign is using both box and G
suite today as well as the box for G
suite integration to be more productive
by we have agenda today we're gonna be
covering I know it's a mixed audience of
folks who might be familiar with box and
folks who aren't as familiar so I want
to spend some time giving a brief
introduction into box and then of course
we want to give an overview of the box
for G suite integration and provide a
live demo so you can see it in action
and then we're gonna bring John Lake up
from DocuSign to do a customer spotlight
Q&A and we also want to make sure that
we have time for audience questions as
well so starting with box I want to just
kick this off by talking about the
mission of box over the past 13 years
we've heard from many companies like
Nike coca-cola and GE and they've all
set a very similar thing which is that
they want to be more efficient they want
to be faster but sometimes technology
stands in the way and so at box our
mission is very simple to power how the
world works together and we work with
companies around the globe of every
industry as you can see here and even
some of the most highly regulated
industries like the public government
financial services companies and help
companies in the healthcare space we
have 87,000 customers today and we're
really excited to be helping to drive
digital transformation for all of these
customers
and digital transformation is on every
company's mind today it's incredibly
important to be as agile in an
increasingly competitive fast-paced
business environment and how we
collaborate and manage our information
is really at the core of digital
transformation because information
touches every business process runs
through every employee at a company and
is incredibly critical to getting
business done but unfortunately the way
that our information is managed today is
fragmented and this is because of the
way that content strategies have evolved
in a very fragmented way over time so
starting kind of in the 90s you had file
shares network drives even physical
media and going to the post office to
transmit content and enterprise content
management solutions such as Stuckey
Menem and SharePoint and Open Text
evolved to provide one central
repository for your content that could
be easily searched and indexed but these
were not built for the end user in mind
and because they weren't as easy to use
they never evolved beyond a few
departmental use cases and then with the
rise in mobility and the need to be able
to work on the go and consumer file sync
and share tools that were very easy to
use and intuitive such as Dropbox and
Microsoft onedrive and cropped up as
well to meet the new demands of the
workforce and then at the same time
application development became popular
again and you have a lot of companies
building their own custom applications
on platform such as AWS and Microsoft
Azure and we've also seen a rise of line
of business cloud applications such as
sales force and workday new new cloud
tools that enhance collaboration such as
slack and workplace by Facebook and all
of this means that your content is
fragmented across all of these different
systems and applications today and for
those dialed in I'd like to just take a
look at this slide and think about how
many different applications you're using
at your organization today such as those
listed here and and you're probably
using multiple today
so what if you had one platform that
worked for all of your content that's
cloud content management from box it's
one platform born in the cloud that
enables seamless and secure internal and
external collaboration provides a single
source of truth for content across your
bus debride applications because it
integrates seamlessly across your
applications it's it automates business
workflows across the extended enterprise
leverages advanced machine learning and
artificial intelligence technologies
from all the major vendors including
Google cloud platform to help automate
business workflows and provide security
and compliance for every industry in geo
without sacrificing simplicity I'd like
to give an overview of what the Box
platform provides at the core you have
the content capabilities the ability to
seamlessly collaborate internally and
externally across teams and automate
workflows apply machine learning and
intelligence to your content but there's
a lot more to that that box offers box
has several native applications I'll
just touch upon a few listed here box
drive which enables you to stream your
box files on your desktop to kind of
imitate a network drive experience and
so taking up very little space but being
able to easily access your files in a
very familiar way box relay which
provides workflow capabilities that are
very end-user focus very simple for the
end-user to set up to automate manual
repeatable workflows box notes which is
a really easy way for teams to
collaborate in real time when they're in
meetings to kind of capture notes as
well as action items and box capture
which enables you to take photos on the
go when you're you're at work this is
great for mobile field teams with with
all of those photos stored securely into
box vs on your personal device those are
just some examples of box apps and as I
mentioned box integrates seamlessly
across a multitude of tools we have over
1,400
application integrations today of course
G suite which we're going to focus on
today but we also integrate with office
365 messaging and collaboration tools
such as slack work placed by Facebook
line of business applications such as
Salesforce and ServiceNow as well as
signatures on solutions such as DocuSign
and Adobe sign and we're excited to have
John join us later on to talk a bit more
about what DocuSign does as well as
workflow and business process management
tools such as an intact and pega and
then box has robust API is and SDKs that
enable companies to build on the Box
platform with box as the content layer
powering applications such as client
portals when you have lots of documents
that you're sharing with internal and
act between internal and external
parties this is a very popular use case
for wealth management mobile field
support for companies that have a big
employee base in the field and custom
digital process this is great for
marketing teams to easily share content
across internal and external parties and
then I really want to highlight on the
last pH piece which is important which
is that all of this resides on a layer
of security and compliance that makes
this all safe to reside in the cloud so
box starting with insights box has over
80 different reports that we offer to IT
admins to get really granular reporting
into how content is being shared and
managed across organization and outside
with box zones we offer the ability for
companies to select where their data
stored to comply with data residency
requirements and we offer multiple
layers of protection and DLP and also
from a governance perspective the
ability to apply legal holds and
retention policies apply retention
policies on your content on your files
on your folders and then through our key
safe product we allow customers to
manage their own ink
Asian keys for ultimate privacy and so I
hope this gives you a sense for what the
box platform provides pretty robust
capabilities beyond just kind of sharing
and managing your content but providing
a variety of apps integrations and a
platform offering to be able to do more
with your content so now I'd like to
dive into the box for G suite
integration why we're all here today a
little bit of background about box box
and Google have been strategic partners
for a few years now and we're working to
together to transform the way
organizations collaborate and do work in
the cloud and we're excited to be
deepening our partnerships through new
integrations over over time so we
launched our hangouts chat integration
earlier this year Docs sheets and slides
which is the focus of today's webinar is
publicly available today through beta
and will be available generally to the
public by end of this year and I'll
provide more details on how to get this
integration we're also going to be
launching our Gmail integration by end
of this year as well we announced this
and shared it at Google next a couple
months ago and I'll also be providing
more details on that integration later
on we also integrate with Google cloud
to provide and the Google cloud platform
to provide Google machine learning
capabilities to box customers to apply
to content to automate business
processes so box 4G suite just by way of
an overview of what this provides we are
bringing the rich experience of Google
Docs sheets and slides directly into box
and so this means that you can
seamlessly leverage Google's familiar
editing experience from within box so
you can create new Google Docs sheets
and slides while ensuring your content
is organized and easily discoverable you
can collaborate in real time with
Google's rich real-time editing
capabilities and Google sheets and
slides and being able to see edits that
are happening in real time with all
changes instantly saved into box and you
can maintain enterprise level standards
so ensuring your content meets the
security compliance and governance of
any industry with our robust security
infrastructure so in terms of key
features that I'll be highlighting in
the demo shortly and you can easily
create new Docs sheets and slides with
any edits that you make to these
documents instantly saved into the box
and you can also see version history in
inbox like you can with any other
document that's managed in box and you
get the robust security of that I
mentioned our governance capabilities to
any files that are saved in box and John
from DocuSign will be joining us shortly
to provide a live customer viewpoint but
I wanted to highlight one of our other
joint customers of the Box 4G suite
integration Indiana University the G
suite is widely used across the
education space and they're using box 4G
suite across 100,000 faculty and
students to share syllabi and to manage
educational content and so with that I'm
going to go into the demo so this is
what the box experience looks like at
over here you can easily search for any
files you can search by file type by the
date it's uploaded by title on the left
you have you can easily access your
recent files you can easily see
notifications if someone left comments
for you to look at a document and you
all your box notes would be stored here
you can also favorite documents so you
can easily refer to them and then over
here you have so I'm I'm in a launch
folder I'm in marketing and I often
collaborate with my product manager
counterparts in this folder and so I can
see everyone who's here I can easily
share the folder and I can depending on
who I want to share
with I can edit permission levels and
stop them from being able to edit maybe
just enabling them to view or preview or
download so box offers pretty granular
permission capabilities there and I'm
going to go ahead and go into a product
spec document because my team I know has
been editing you can see here they're in
the docx editing it right now and I know
that they left me some comments so let
me go ahead and go into this I also want
to highlight you can easily download
share and you can share documents in
slack and other integrations directly
from here but I'm gonna go ahead and
open this into Google Docs so here's
this product spec document I just want
to take a look at it I know that the
team left some comments ok they're
working on prioritizing some features oh
great this functionality is something
that I've been waiting for that's great
thanks for the update booth all in caps
and then you can resolve comments and
then if I make any edits you can see
here at the top all changes are saved in
box and so this is really important your
when you enable this integration any
documents that are created from within
box any Google Docs sheets or slides
documents are saved in a box not in
Google Drive and and so that's really
important to enable that one central
repository for all of your content so
I'm going to go ahead and close out of
this document go back into box and I
also want to share one other thing that
box provides which is that you're able
to actually take office file so this is
an XLS file an excel file and I actually
choose to open this with Google sheets
so what its gonna do is convert that
excel file into Google sheets I can make
edits let's just say I want to change
this and all of those
it's will be saved back to the original
file format so they'll be saved back
into Excel and so you can see here a new
version was just uploaded would you like
to refresh the page and then here I'll
be able to access the latest version and
there's been 27 versions saved you can
you can access all of your version
history here and then the last thing you
want to share is that you can this is
where you can actually create any new
Google Doc sheets slides and sheets
files as well as any office files so I
just want to show what the experience
looks like if I create a new document
and you talk
it'll immediately launch and any edits I
make in this document will be managed
and saved securely back into box this is
going a bit slow but yeah so you can see
kind of how you can also create net new
files as well so with that I'm going to
go back into into the slides I also want
to highlight that in addition to our
integration with Docs sheets and slides
box for Gmail will be coming soon by end
of this year as well and what this
offers is the ability to access box
content from within Gmail and you can
change permissions to any files you can
attach box links directly into emails
and then when you get an email that has
an attachment you can save that
attachment directly into box and select
which folder you'd like to save that to
so just making it super seamless to work
in the tools that you're working in
every day but ensuring that all of your
content is as managed in box and so with
that I'd love to bring up John lake from
DocuSign for a customer Q&A
great John thank you for joining us
today well thanks for fighting me happy
to be here can you tell us a little bit
about DocuSign sure and their role there
yeah absolutely AB DocuSign has been
around since about 2003 I think we are
largely known as an e-signature company
but we're also helping to fuel a lot of
the digital transformation initiatives
through our system of agreement where
we're helping customers prepare or sign
but also act and manage on the content
that drives their their digital
transactions great and can you tell me a
little bit about the unique challenges
that you face from an IT standpoint
mm-hmm
yeah DocuSign is a hyper growth company
we have been growing rapidly largely
over the last four to five years
although we've been around for a little
while a tremendous influx of employees
over the last couple years I think
recent metric I saw internally was about
65% of our employees have been at
DocuSign for two to three years so very
diverse globally distributed workforce
weren't about we have 15 offices
distributed globally so yeah I think the
challenges that come with hyper growth
are the challenges that we're facing
absolutely and how does this how do
these trends kind of impact the IT tools
that you select for DocuSign yeah again
a lot of influx of new people hyper
growth means that there's been a lot of
organic growth of tools internally we
try and choose and drive the use of
standards internally but of course that
is difficult with inside DocuSign we
have to productivity Suites
it gets percentage of our users who are
on Google G suite and we have a good
percentage of our users who are on the
office suite so what we try and do is
drive the solutions that make things
easy to use but also allow us to drive
the standards and meet the security and
compliance initiatives that that were
subject to that's great and what are
your key priorities in terms of security
and compliance I think yeah and to
simply put it to to be as secure as
possible but also trying to strike the
right balance between security and
productivity right of course DocuSign to
trust brand we take
incredibly seriously but we also are a
software company that's trying to
innovate and drive new use cases as
quickly as possible so I think striking
that balance is incredibly important to
us to make sure that we do that as
effectively as possible and I can
imagine you're probably dealing with
some sensitive information with legal
contracts and whatnot yeah certainly
DocuSign again and being well-known as
an e-signature
company a lot of contracts a lot of
transactional data that's flowing
through a lot of PII is it stored in
this information and of course we want
to maintain as much security around that
as possible yep and what were you using
before you started using boxes your
content platform
yeah DocuSign has been a box customer
for about five years all over five years
prior that what a lot of other folks
were using right file servers
distributed around our different offices
local connections and the things that
come along with that yeah and so in
terms of the Box 4G suite integration
can you talk a bit about how this new
integration is gonna kind of help solve
some challenges help kind of add value
to your employees in the tools that
they're using every day yeah yeah like I
said I think we have a about half of our
organization that's running G suite the
other half is using o 365 I think one of
the challenges that we had we've been
again been a box customer for about five
years but we've had great content
management on the back end with box
right we've had the enterprise class
security administration and content
management tools that come along with
box but of course we haven't until now
very recently been able to apply those
controls to the percentage of our user
base that is running G suite so I think
coming along with the G suite connector
now what we'll be able to do is help
drive and facilitate a standard content
management backend where we can take
those robust security content management
administration controls that we've
otherwise been able to employ with o 365
and be able to leverage those with with
G suite as well that's great so what
aspect of this new integration are you
most excited about yeah I think that
aspect that we just
just talked about right which is that
ability from us from internal enterprise
applications IT perspective right to be
able to maintain the visibility and the
governance around the significant amount
of content that's originated and
maintained in G suite as well as being
able to apply those same things you know
of course to or 365 but giving us that
single pane of glass that single ability
to drive that governance from the IT
perspective versus having to maintain
two distinct silos where we had to do
that in the past yep
and I know that you're a cloud forest
company are you using other cloud tools
or your employees using other cloud
tools in their day-to-day today to get
their work done that and you've
integrated box with or that you're
looking to yeah yeah we have of course
we are a cloud first company and I think
probably the best example of that is
Salesforce is a good work brought
workplace tool right this use broadly
across the organization integrates with
box and again gives us a way to start
driving better standard content
management behavior content management
governance you know through the backend
that's great and for those of you who
are unfamiliar with how the Salesforce
integration works with box it
essentially brings box directly into
Salesforce so your sales reps can easily
access all of their files and folders
directly from the opportunity or record
and so with that I'd love to open it up
to the audience so stay tuned for live
Q&A for questions for either me or John
we'll be back in less than a minute
hi everybody welcome back and before we
go into the audience questions I want to
just provide some information on how to
contact box if you have additional
questions and just a quick email address
you can email us at with any questions
as sales at box comm and if you're
interested in the beta of the Google
Docs sheets and slides integration the
public beta is available to anyone today
you can go to this URL that's listed
here box comm slash partner slash Google
and there will be a link with
instructions for how you can enable this
beta and then this will be generally
available to the public by end of year
so we hope that you are excited to use
this integration and I also want to
highlight that the box for Gmail add-on
that I reviewed as well will be
available generally to the public by end
of year so with that I'm going to go
ahead and take our first question our
Google Docs created on box accessible
outside box via Google Drive Docs or
Google Docs Google com etc and so know
that's the great thing about this
integration is that any Docs that are
created in box are going to be managed
and secured in box and they won't be
accessible from any other place and this
is so that IT I'm sure John recognizes
the importance of this and he talked
about it and can kind of centrally
manage everything in one place there's a
question for John which is and you said
you were using on-premise content
solutions before how did you centralize
all of that on the box yeah it was a not
a quick exercise it's definitely not the
flip of a switch it's more the turn of a
knob over time and what we did is just
we just bit it off in small chunks right
what I think one of the first things we
did is we make sure everybody's aware
communicate out you know what we're
doing why we're doing it what the
benefits and impact of the organization
are by making this move from an
on-premise storage solution to the cloud
and then of course we we look for
champions around the organization right
as we start to deploy this we find
target good use cases for this for us
internally as an example our marketing
organization did a lot of interaction
with external agencies so having a
content management system where they
could collaborate internally right
relatively simply easily quickly across
platform so it's great but then of
course you have a lot of input and
feedback from your external agencies so
again targeting a good use case getting
some early quick wins with it to build
some momentum with it and then just
staying adamant right almost about the
progression of rolling this out and then
turning down and rolling off of those
those file servers I think overall over
the course of the execution we moved
about a little over 40 terabytes worth
of data in the box that's great and
that's actually you touched upon
something that comes up a lot with
customers who selected box is that with
their previous content platforms it's
not so easy to share files externally
and so as an example some customers who
might be using the office suite and they
have to toggle between onedrive and
SharePoint they have to use SharePoint
for external sharing onedrive for
internal sharing and so that's that's
great that you highlighted that and then
the other thing you noted which also
comes up a lot is kind of that chain the
need for change management and to
provide training to your employees to
drive adoption of these tools I think
box is very user friendly as its
DocuSign as this.g suite but it's
important to have those early wins as
well as absolutely employees what do we
agree and so another question that came
in
does this integration require a Google
account that's a great question this
integration is available to customers
with paid G suite accounts and so as
long as you have a page view suite
account you're eligible to use this
integration and it's completely free can
multiple users simultaneously edit a
scene single document and yes absolutely
that's one of the great benefits of G
suite enabling that real time
collaboration
and so they can they can edit it they
can resolve comments and with all
changes saved and it box which Google
editors are included Google Docs sheets
and slides and as I mentioned and showed
in the demo and you can actually convert
office files into G suite files and any
edits will be saved back into the
original file format and then someone is
asking about how to access the public
beta and so the public beta and if you
go to box comm slash partner slash
Google and there'll be a link to be able
to sign up for the beta um but it will
be generally available to the public by
end of year which is great because
anyone will be able to if you're a box
admin you can just enable it in your
admin console those are all of the
questions stay tuned for the next
session extending Google's grab-and-go
program to your business John thank you
for joining us it was a pleasure thank
you thank you everyone